- What do you want to hear a rap about?
Hand up down here, yeah.
The Civil War.
Wonderful.
Just straight out of the
gate at the British boy
who, I don't know if you know this,
in England, we don't learn about that.
(crowd laughs)
As soon as we lost this country,
we're like, well it's yours now.
We don't care.
(crowd laughs)
The Civil War, the Civil War.
We'll take that as a suggestion.
Hand up on the front row, yes.
- [Woman] Azerbaijan.
- Azerbaijan, and you pronounced
it in a way that suggests,
are you from Azerbaijan?
No, it's just cause you said, Azerbaijan,
and I was like, I always
thought it was 'Azerbyjan',
and now I've been educated.
You're a travel blogger?
Ooh, get you, well done.
What's your favorite
thing about Azerbaijan?
- [Woman] Its great architecture.
- Its great architecture.
I'm glad you said that,
because I was looking
for some helpful info.
The Civil War, Azerbaijan,
and its great architecture.
Section over here.
What do you want to rap about?
- [Man] The Kama Sutra.
- The Kama Sutra.
(crowd laughs)
Yeah, you strike me as that kind of guy.
I mean I love sex, but I do
also like to be prepared.
You know, it's good to know the positions.
Azerbaijan, and the architecture of it,
the Civil War, the Kama Sutra.
Guys over here.
Yeah, you're waving a phone very brightly.
Yes, sir.
Detroit.
(crowd cheers)
I mean, some would say it's
too obvious a suggestion,
but I feel like I have to take it.
I will take it.
Any particular aspect of Detroit
that you want us to really focus on?
(crowd yells)
Everybody has their own opinions on this
and he's looking around
to try and crowdsource it.
(crowd yelling)
How much drink you've got?
Oh grit.
Detroit, and how much grit you have.
I like that, thank you very much.
You can sit down now, sir.
That was a very good,
just like, I'll stand
up, this is my moment.
(crowd laughs)
Now we're going to take one final one.
This can come from anywhere.
It has to be really good though.
What are you saying?
What?
- [Man] Wanker.
- This man is just shouting
wanker at the side of the stage.
(crowd laughs)
Wait, is it a suggestion?
Is it a heckle?
You've been doing it since I walked on.
That's why I was like, I can't,
I don't know if it is a man shouting
or it's just my dad's voice
in my head being like,
you're a wanker, son.
You're a disappointment.
I mean, it sounds awful coming
out of any American's mouth,
but I will happily take it.
So we have the Civil War,
Azerbaijan's architecture,
Detroit and how much grit you have,
the Kama Sutra and the
British phrase, wanker,
which I will explain what it means,
but throughout the song.
This then lovely people of
the Masonic temple in Detroit,
of the Forbes 30 under 30,
this is gonna be a freestyle rap.
That is a rap made up on the spot,
based entirely on those suggestions.
If people walk in when I'm doing it,
tell them it's made up on the spot,
because otherwise it's
going to look really shit.
(crowd laughs)
It's never been written.
It's never going to be seen
again and do not worry.
It will not be anywhere
near as atrociously,
embarrassingly bad,
as you're expecting a privately educated,
middle class white British boy to be.
Thank you very much for those people
who seem very unconvinced.
This is gonna be fun.
If we can drop the beat, my friend.
Let's show him how we do.
(crowd cheers)
Yeah!
(hip hop beat starts)
And crank that up on
here for me a little bit.
I'm going to start with yours first,
because it was such a nice suggestion.
A fist bump for the start, yeah.
♪ A fist bump I touch my
skin on that hand there ♪
♪ Man on stage left saying
Chris you're a wanker ♪
♪ What does it mean? ♪
♪ I'll define it for you ♪
♪ If you are a guy you go
down to your balls, ya ♪
♪ Like to have a hand
shandy you might thank ♪
♪ For having the penis,
it's called having a wank ♪
♪ A section of masturbation ♪
♪ Call me a wanker then my
frustration is apparent ♪
♪ It's basically a horrible cuss ♪
♪ If you call me it we'll get fisticuffs ♪
♪ I might get rough with you but I won't ♪
♪ Cause you've got muscles
and I clearly don't ♪
♪ But that is okay we
can make best friends. ♪
♪ It sounds real good
in a British accent ♪
♪ But if you shout it at
me I wouldn't thank ya ♪
♪ In American it sounds like it's wanker ♪
♪ It doesn't sound nice
I've heard it before ♪
♪ The last time I said it
was during the Civil War ♪
♪ I saw all the bad
guys open their mouths ♪
♪ I said you're wankers
go back to the South ♪
♪ They did ♪
♪ Admittedly I didn't fight in it ♪
♪ I wasn't alive I
couldn't make that finish ♪
♪ And people say Chris you rap and sing ♪
♪ But have you ever seen
Gone With The Wind ♪
♪ That's true I did ♪
♪ It's four hours long ♪
♪ I'm watching it going parts
of this are really wrong ♪
♪ They make me feel really dicey. ♪
♪ But look at this she's
wearing a nice dress, see ♪
♪ Scarlett O'Hara that was in the novel ♪
♪ Lived in a nice house never in a hovel ♪
♪ Civil War it's really not that fun ♪
♪ Unless you like
looking at massive guns ♪
♪ Abraham Lincoln back in the days ♪
♪ He was like yeah we'll
free the South from slavery ♪
♪ Admittedly I'm not sure
that was his main thing ♪
♪ He was like well I'm
inviting everybody in ♪
♪ I'm peering right to the future ♪
♪ You and me backstage do the Kama Sutra ♪
♪ I'll get the book
out it's all the rage ♪
♪ I will do every position on every page ♪
♪ Upside down maybe inside out ♪
♪ I'll thrust so hard that I turn it out ♪
♪ I'm really sorry to
put that in this rap ♪
♪ It's horrible a Kama Sutra prolapse ♪
♪ Where does it come from English man ♪
♪ I believe originally it's Indian ♪
♪ From the subcontinent
and then I go near ♪
♪ I travel up here cause I got no fear ♪
♪ Far and wide like my blogging ma'am ♪
♪ I go on a holiday Azerbaijan ♪
♪ Chris why would you
go and see the country ♪
♪ Well cause I like the Grand Prix ♪
♪ That's motor racing Formula One ♪
♪ A Grand Prix there,
circuit they've got one ♪
♪ But the best thing if
you really are able ♪
♪ Look at the architecture
it's so stable ♪
♪ Built with triangles
you can't get off it ♪
♪ Nice Baroque domes none of that gothic ♪
♪ No brutalism the streets are complete ♪
♪ It's more kind of
Baroque but no concrete ♪
♪ I don't like that ♪
♪ Last thing I'm gonna spit ♪
♪ I'm in Detroit and we know
you guys got a lot of grit ♪
♪ You've got a lot of stones ♪
♪ You've got a lot of balls. ♪
♪ So many of y'all in this very hall ♪
♪ Have got the grit too ♪
♪ It means you're gritty and tough ♪
♪ It means you always think
yeah it's never enough ♪
♪ I'm gonna stick to the end ♪
♪ Hang it till the finish ♪
♪ There we go Detroit yeah
like a little cymbal swish ♪
Boom, there you go.
(crowd applauds)
(Chris laughs)